leon panetta has served as white house
chief of staff head of the cia and the
u.s defense secretary he told us that
the french should really be more
supportive more on that in a moment but
first i began by asking him for his
reaction to this week's admission that
one of america's last acts in
afghanistan a drone strike in kabul had
killed 10 innocent people
it's not good news uh i look uh
drone strikes or weapons of war
and you have to
exercise tremendous
caution
when you're targeting
with a drone
as someone who's been involved involved
with drone operations as
director of the cia
i thought it was very important
to have
intelligence not only
using our surveillance capability but
also
using people on the ground spies on the
ground
to identify those targets and make sure
that
we had the right targets when we fired
in this instance it's pretty clear that
that kind of care was not exercised
and a terrible mistake has been made
and it does reflect badly i think on the
the approach
that was used to decide what target to
hit i know there was a tremendous amount
of confusion i know there was a
tremendous amount of pressure
to try to go after those that had killed
our marines
and killed others
but that's no excuse
for not developing accurate information
when it comes to targeting individuals
do you think that this kind of mistake
let's call it that
weakens the united states hand in its
foreign policy and its work to try to
extend its influence across the globe
well look at any anytime
this kind of mistake is made
uh it uh it reflects badly
uh in terms of
the mythology
of
applying
our technology to
targets on the ground
now you know having said that
we live in a very dangerous world
uh and we're dealing with a lot of
adversaries
whether it's russia whether it's china
whether it's iran whether it's north
korea
whether it's failed states in the middle
east whether it's terrorism
and
the fact is that we still are at war
with terrorism
i think the result in afghanistan is
that
we have a taliban
that will probably continue to provide
safe haven
to terrorists like al qaeda and isis and
haqqanis and others
and so we're going to have to
make sure
that in dealing with that threat to our
national security
uh yes we're going to need the very best
intelligence we can get on those targets
to the extent that a mistake was made
here
yes
it's something that
we have to worry about we have to
investigate as to what happened
and we have to make sure that it never
happens again
can i turn now to
wider issues of foreign policy
is it fair to say that the biden
administration's
foreign policy has just one overwhelming
priority china
well there's no question that uh
china is a priority
but
i i'm not sure you can call it
the only overwhelming priority we have
we're probably facing more flash points
in the world than we face since the end
of world war ii
because it isn't just china
it's also russia which has become much
more aggressive
in their actions particularly towards
the united states
iran is continuing
to enrich fuel
and is getting closer to the capability
of having a nuclear weapon
north korea is now firing more missiles
and developing more nuclear weapons
and we are continuing to see terrorism
and we're continuing to see cyber
attacks which is the battlefield of the
future
so we're dealing with a lot of threats
and yes china is one of those
but the united states has to be capable
of being able to respond
to national security threats across the
board
and that means that we have to be strong
enough militarily and diplomatically to
be able to deal with those challenges
when the do you were
the
chief of staff in the white house um
your administration was pretty clear on
china it
thought that the globalization and
economic growth would lead to greater
freedom
and a different relationship with china
and reform in china itself
it hasn't worked out that way has it
unfortunately uh it has not worked out
that way
and there's been a lot of mistakes along
the way
i think president obama was right when
he talked about rebalancing our force to
the pacific i was secretary of defense
when we made that decision
and it was important to do that
uh in order to make clear to china that
yes we will work with them we will have
dialogue with them we'll try to deal
with them economically and financially
as as we have
but at the same time
we are also going to protect our
national interests
when it comes to the pacific which means
that the south china sea
cannot
be an area
that limits the ability of shipping
and free trade
and freedom of the seas to be able to
take place
it means that we have to respect human
rights
it means that we have to protect uh
taiwan
it means that we have to make sure that
the right thing is done with regards to
hong kong as well
so
yes we we can have that dialogue
but at the same time i think we have to
be prepared
in order to show china
that there are lines that they cannot
cross
is the pact signed this week between the
united states uh the united kingdom and
australia to provide australia with
nuclear-powered submarines
uh
a preparation as you've just
talked about or is it as the chinese are
saying a provocation
i think it's about engagement and i
think it's about deterrence
i think that's that's the message that
they should get uh
you know i
i think that the
the most important thing
that needs to be done
uh in dealing with china is to
strengthen our alliances the one thing
the chinese don't do very well is have
allies
that's not something that works well for
them same thing is true for russia
they don't like other countries
developing alliances that might limit
them
in the decisions they make
and so i think the fact that uh
we announced this security partnership
and that we made clear
that we are going to be able to exchange
not only intelligence
but also
technologies
and we're going to help provide
nuclear-powered submarines to the
australians
so that they can have that capability
i think what that does is it sends a
message to china
that
we are not going to simply sit back
and allow china to have its way in the
pacific but there's a price to pay here
isn't there and that is in the terms of
america's own allies
the deal that you signed with the uk and
australia has made the french furious
the french foreign minister described it
as a stab in the back and the elysee
palace has uh recalled its ambassador to
the united states
this is a misstep isn't it
well you know i i'm i'm not sure of just
exactly what kind of conversations went
on
with regards to our allies france and
others as well
i would hope
that when this kind of partnership is
announced
that
our other allies would support that kind
of partnership because very frankly uh
the role of allies is to build
partnerships
and to be able to work together when it
comes to security
when it comes to
our economics when it comes to trade etc
that's that's that's the heart and soul
of having allies let me just ask you
this though
that the french said that uh the this
behavior
looks like something that mr trump would
do isn't that the biggest insult that
anybody could level at a biden white
house
well yeah
he yeah and it's probably not accurate
because uh i i'm not sure that uh
president trump
uh had the ability to develop the kind
of partnerships
that the biden administration developed
in this case the kind of strategic
partnership
between the united kingdom uh australia
and the united states uh that was not
something that trump was very interested
in doing so but you see my point
it is a it's a criticism but i don't
think it's based on fact but you see my
point here that the biden administration
is about to go into cop 26.
it's meant to give us world give the
world leadership it's meant to bring
people together but by its actions
uh the pulling out of afghanistan uh
this particular uh
thing with the french
that it is alienating potentially people
is going to need to help it do the deal
at cop 26 for example
uh you know look i i think president
biden has made clear
that the united states uh wants to
exercise world leadership and wants to
work
with our allies in the world and
you know have mistakes been made
of course they've been made
but
overall
i think that
it's pretty clear that this president
understands
the importance of countries working
together
in order to provide for our mutual
security
and i i guess my you know it to some
extent look there there is a problem
here because uh after
watching trump a lot of our allies
basically were very distrustful of the
united states i understand that
uh and we're starting to operate on
their own and france is a good example
of that
but i i also think that they should
recognize that
we have a different president
who is interested
in trying to work with the rest of the
world
and
we will have our differences
we will make mistakes okay but in the
end if we're confronting common
adversaries as we are in china and
russia and elsewhere
then we damn well better start working
together